saluons enfin savoir oui mais dis donc
là j'ai vu le titre de la vidéo j'ai une
question je t'écoute modifier son adn
ouais ça voudrait dire par exemple
changer un truc génétique chez nous oui
en gros c'est d'aider pourquoi non mais
moi ça m'intéresse parce que par exemple
s'est toujours révélé de noms oui alors
non cette place est pas le même est-ce
que tu connais les coiffeurs coloriste
oui oui eh ben c'est pas du tout de ça
dont on va parler
peut-on modifier notre adn bon je vais
pas sympa j'ai pas faire d'efforts
seraient vous obliger à rester jusqu'à
la fin pour avoir la réponse
d'autant que vous la connaissez
peut-être déjà oui normal restait quand
même parce que le plus intéressant c'est
comment on fait ça et pourquoi on fait
ça alors déjà on va se mettre un peu
d'accord sur les mots parce que tout le
monde les connaît mais il ya pas mal de
trucs un peu mystique qui tourne autour
de tout ce qui touche à la génétique
l'adn
déjà c'est quoi bref l'adn c'est l'acide
désoxyribonucléique voilà des bruins
non il s'agit évidemment d'un procédé au
pilon poursuivons donc pour résumer on a
dans le noyau de chacune de nos cellules
va pas tout tout ne va pas chipoter 46
chromosomes composés chacun d'adr et
dans cet adn il ya nos gènes et chaque
gène contient une information
particulière qui correspond à une
fonction particulière tous à sa forme ce
qu'on appelle notre génome c'est à dire
notre patrimoine génétique et donc alors
ces gènes à quoi il sert et bah ses
gènes
il commande notamment la production de
plein de protéines différentes qui ont
chacune un rôle spécifique faire
fonctionner les muscles par exemple ça
vous le saviez si vous poussez un peu à
la salle mais il ya aussi l'hémoglobine
donc vous avez sans doute déjà entendu
parler qui est une de ces protéines dont
le boulot c'est de transporter l'oxygène
jusqu'à nos organes ou encore les
immunoglobulines les anticorps dont vous
avez sans doute moi aussi entendu parler
ces derniers temps et qui sont aussi les
protéines et y en a pleins pleins
d'autres comptent chacune un rôle
spécifique nécessaire au bon
fonctionnement de notre petite machine
personnelle
notre corps le problème c'est que le
code contenu dans ses gènes celui qui
leur permet de faire ce qu'ils ont à
faire
il peut avoir des anomalies des erreurs
si vous voulez ces anomalies soit on les
a depuis la naissance
soit elles apparaissent au cours de
notre vie parce qu'il ya des erreurs de
grubby au nom de la division élue dans
tous les cas elles peuvent donner des
maladies ce qui nous amène à notre sujet
alors ok il ya un truc cassé mais est ce
qu'on peut se réparer
ben je vous exposerai dans l'intro de la
vidéo oui on peut on le fait même déjà
avec ce qui s'appelle les thérapies
géniques thérapie traitement génique les
gènes ou la veille mais encore une fois
le plus intéressant c'est comment on
fait ça déjà globalement une thérapie
génique ça consiste à faire une
modification génétique des cellules une
modification extrêmement précises ciblée
sur les gènes qui fonctionnent pas
correctement mais parce que sinon ça n'a
aucun sens c est pour faire ça il ya
plusieurs techniques soit on introduit
un gène programmé pour soigner la
maladie soit on désactive dans nos
cellules
le gène qui pose problème et qui est à
l'origine de la maladie soit on modifie
le gène qui nous viennent pour qu'ils se
mettent à fonctionner comme il faut soit
on remplace carrément le gène qui
marchent pas bien malins gènes qui
marche correctement pour agir
directement sur la cause de la maladie
dans tous les cas vous avez remarqué il
faut introduire un truc dans nos
cellules et ça c'est pas facile parce
que des cellules on en a plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de milliards
donc c'est un peu long de les modifier
une par une et puis en plus il faut
cibler les bonnes cellules et cela même
si on a une très bonne vue c'est pas
facilement donc l'idée pour amener les
jeunes à bon port
c'est de trouver un perceur de coffres
et comme dans les films de braquage
candidats cherchent les meilleurs dans
leur domaine là le profil recherché
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît bien le
business des cellules quelqu'un qui va
être capable de reconnaître les cellules
qu'on veut cibler et puis surtout qui va
être capable de rentrer dedans d'où le
logique avec personne et bas se profile
on l'a trouvée c'est des virus oui parce
que les virus c'est exactement comme ça
que fonctionne il repère une cellule y
rentre dedans
et après ils font comme chez eux ils
mettent les pieds sur la table et tout
mais surtout y déposent leur propre
matériel génétique dans la cellule et
ils se multiplient grâce à elle alors du
calme je vois au lèvre inférieure qui
commence à trembloter là non on
n'introduit pas une maladie virale pour
soigner une autre maladie
le virus qui va servir de vecteurs c'est
à dire de moyen de locomotion
on commence par lui retirer son propre
bagage génétique
celui qui rend malade et on le remplace
par les gènes sein ceux qui vont
permettre de soigner
ensuite il reste plus qu à l'injecter
dans notre organisme
le virus lui il pense qu'il fait son
boulot comme d'habitude sauf que ce
qu'il introduit dans nos cellules c'est
un médicament il ya des chercheurs qui
essaie de trouver d'autres véhicules
pour transporter le matériel génétique
vers les bonnes cellules mais pour
l'instant c'est ces virus dénué de toute
propriété malfaisantes qui sont utilisés
et ça fonctionne très bien
donc vous avez compris le principe on
nous dit fille pas globalement tout
notre adn on n'en répare une partie qui
est abîmée pour soigner les maladies qui
sont nés de cette anomalie
de quelle maladie on parle exactement
les thérapies géniques ça existe depuis
les années 60
c'est à cette période qu'on a commencé à
les développer au départ elles ont
surtout été envisagée pour soigner des
maladies dans lesquelles il y avait qu
un seul gène ne marchait pas bien mais
les progrès de la recherche font
qu'aujourd'hui on s'attaque à des trucs
un peu plus complexe il ya deux
chercheuses qu'on aime identifiés en
un processus qui permet de couper les
séquences entières d' adn comme avec une
paire de ciseaux et de les remplacer
ça s'appelle chris peur et les
scientifiques en question la française
emmanuelle charpentier et l'américaine
jennifer d'oudhna ont reçu le prix nobel
de chimie en 2020 pour leurs découvertes
les premières recherches elles ont
concerné les bébés bulles ceux des bébés
qui sont nés avec un système immunitaire
très déficient voir sans aucune défense
et qui nécessite qu'ils soient placés
sous une
pour les protéger des agressions
extérieures comme les infections
d'où le nom qu'on leur donne il ya
d'autres recherches qui se sont tournés
vers une maladie de la rétine qu'on
appelle l'amaurose congénitale de les
bears et provoque une malvoyance voire
d'une cécité c'est à dire le fait d'être
un homme pour le moment au total il ya
moins d'une dizaine de traitement qu'on
passait toutes les étapes et qui ont
reçu les autorisations pour être utilisé
et oui parce que mais maintenant vous
savez ça mettre au point ce genre de
thérapie entre la phase de recherche
les essais cliniques etc c'est très long
et comme on l'a vu on se penche dessus
que depuis les années 60 mais les
thérapies géniques ça représente un vrai
espoir de trouver des solutions pour des
maladies pour lesquelles il y en a peu
voire pas du tout aujourd'hui il ya un
très grand nombre de recherches qui sont
menées en ce moment alors parmi ces
maladies on parle aussi bien de diabète
de maladies cardiovasculaires de
certains types de myopathie des maladies
neurodégénératives comme alzheimer ou
parkinson
l'hémophilie la mucoviscidose mais aussi
des maladies rares et de nombreuses
formes de cancer ça représente même une
majorité des essais en cours actuel donc
vous avez compris c'est encore jeune
mais les thérapies géniques c'est une
piste très prometteuse pour l'avenir et
il ya du monde qui plonge de on estime
même qu'entre 2020 et 2021 il ya une
vingtaine de nouvelles thérapies génique
qui pourraient être mis sur le marché
donc on en est qu'au début mais vous
devriez en entendre parler dans l'est
voilà détester c'est fini pour
aujourd'hui on se retrouve très vite
pour de nouvelles vidéos d'ici là prenez
soin de vous et prenez soin des autres
mettez vous bien et surtout portez vous
bien